con lágrimas e impotencia muchos
ciudadanos de la palma se apresuraron a
recoger algunas de sus pertenencias ante
el avance de la lava derivada de la
erupción del volcán de la isla canarias
los ríos de magma han destrozado muchas
casas a su paso y han obligado a la
evacuación de miles de personas desde el
domingo
y mostramos con nervios estamos sacando
lo más esencial sus colchones la nevera
y un poquito así tener más que sea algo
que estamos locos de hielo cosas que nos
dejaron dos horitas una hora y media
para sacar lo más social muchos
afectados tienen que conformarse con
mirar a lo lejos los daños causados por
la erupción sin poder hacer nada para
frenar el material volcánico una
frustración que el gobierno regional
comparte y que no se puede hacer
absolutamente nada y esa es la
impotencia se ante el avance de esa
colada
que va a unos 200 metros por hora y que
ya ha llevado por delante vivienda ante
la destrucción en la isla y la
desesperación de los locales por perder
sus casas el gobierno central prometió
encargarse de todas las reconstrucciones
necesarias gestión de la crisis
terminará cuando la palma haya
recuperado su normalidad y hayamos
logrado entre todas las administraciones
reconstruir todo aquello que va a
destrozar lo que ha destrozado ya por
desgracia el volcán y la lava el
recorrido del magma está avanzando a un
ritmo más lento del esperado razón por
la que todavía no ha llegado al mar y
cuando lo haga podría generar
explosiones tóxicas algo para lo que las
autoridades locales se están preparando